hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes We are continuing
our uh Ascension towards 2300 and we'll
see if we can get by with what we were
using so far or we will have to improve
on some Theory before uh continuing now
I I'm making a lunch here uh so I do
have a time to play a rapid game and uh
that means that I'm literally working
for my meal here it's it's even a good
idea to sometimes skip a meal if you
lose a game uh that will that will
definitely make you uh a better player
and also it's good for your uh for your
health so uh let's start the game uh
it's going to be sorry uh I have to
create it like this 10 minutes some of
you are asking in the comments why do I
create it this way when there's already
a 10 plus um button here uh because I
always set it to play against the higher
rated opponent see I don't allow uh any
ratings to go in minus I always try to
play at least my rating or 500 rating
points high rated opponent uh no idea
why I've always played like this
um I guess it's uh you know if I win you
you get more rating and if you uh lose
you you lose less rating so you you
climb the the ladder more more quickly
and also you get stronger you you get to
play against stronger opponent so it's a
win-win however you put it so that's why
I do it as some of you are asking in the
comments why do I do that uh but yeah
let's check it out yesterday was Bruce
Le's birthday so we will we will be like
water this game if uh if it's possible
uh so we get the white pieces uh again
we we got the white piece last game and
our opponent is uh Angel like 66 we
don't know who uh who or where from so
he goes for E5 and we're going to
continue with Knight to F3 so Knight to
F6 okay the pet of Defense uh usually uh
in a Blitz game I will even go for
Knight captures on E5 followed by Knight
captures on F7 I don't uh I don't uh
recommend you to do this so standard is
just to capture uh and then go back with
the Knight that's how you do it uh but
uh yeah now Knight captures on e4 and
we're going to play D4 he's going to
play this and we're going to play Bishop
to D3 uh so uh he pretty much uh plays
his moves instantly so he's yeah I know
sometimes C4 is the move um
uh he will he will show me how this is
played no worries no worries there let's
go
here uh so now obviously I'm attacking
the Knight twice he will have to defend
it or he will trade here no he goes for
this uh we're going to Castle we're
going to Castle go Rook E1 uh go Knight
F1 and Knight to G3 that's how we're
going to do it Go Rook E1 he will play
Queens side castles no he won't let's go
here
um
yeah of course we're not going to go
Knight to G3 as while his his Knight is
there so how do we play this let's uh
slow down a little bit we don't have to
rush
it uh yeah our Knight is definitely
coming to F1 and we're going to decide
uh later on how to how to
proceed so it's going to be a queenside
castle it's very
interesting that's very interesting
indeed all right so let's go B4 not
right away of course the C3 Pawn would
be hanging uh but we we do want to play
it at some point so let's go A4
first
no
it's very
interesting yeah he's going to play
G5 he's going to go G5 next but
uh yeah this is very interesting okay
let's go Knight E three let's go for
that F5 Pawn first let's make him work
uh let's make him work for for
that so now he has to decide whether to
push
F4 right
away but then sort of give me the G4
Square for my knight or will he play G6
sort of stopping his plans of
G5 uh it's the best I could come up with
yeah this is uh this game I feel like
this game will be a great uh opportunity
for me to to study how to play against
the Petro properly in in slow
chess uh we'll see we'll see how it goes
but yeah if he doesn't uh if he he will
he's obviously a strong player yeah he
will play something that's
um uh that's good but
uh
yeah this is the quite
scary quite scary
indeed yeah I'm just going to play
Bishop to E2 there's
a there's no reason for my Bishop to be
on D3 not like uh this Knight is ever
moving we do we do like the pressure
here uh but yeah it's just uh too much
to to handle yeah we need to move that
Queen yeah I've messed something up here
so we'll see how he how he takes
advantage of it hopefully he doesn't
but we will we will have to study this
what we've what we've done wrong and
improve yeah G5 is coming that goes
without saying
uh G5 is coming but is it now that
dangerous
huh yeah let's go E5 here
Knight E5 not
E5 yeah he will
take I will of course take with the Rook
with the
Rook he will take here I will take here
he will take here
hopefully and I will finally get some
some play for for that pawn but it's the
best I could uh it's the best I could
come up with I could even grab here I
mean do I want to go for some sort of a
tricky move like Queen
A4 that he can simply defend or do I
just want to take the pawn
here not really threatening anything
so yeah Knight captur could also be a
move but yeah I I think I I I kind of
have to play Queen Capt or he will just
be too
strong yeah we're going to play play
that uh not sure if he trades here or
not yeah he doesn't he wants to go for
Queen to H2 so he wants me to
trade uh do I have anything
better I don't think I do like I could
play G3 but doesn't seem like uh it's
all that impressive okay so let's go
here no is there something better can we
somehow make use of this that the bishop
is
undefended yeah not so much yeah let's
go
here the question is do I give up the
bishop uh the Knight for the bishop if
he plays Bishop to D6 probably I
do since he will have to mess up his
Pawn structure yeah so he's going to go
here and uh now how do we
develop yeah let's go let's go Bishop
here Bishop here we attack the pawn he
defends the pawn I play Rook D1 he plays
F4 I play Bishop D4 that's our that's
our game
plan yeah so I feel like uh I feel like
I got more out of the game than I should
have but still he does have enough
active position but I don't think that
he has more than that I think active
position is all that he
has like G4 is nice yeah he will go for
that first yeah it's a good idea
stopping Rook to D1
definitely definitely a good idea and he
doesn't care about Bishop captur because
of course he has
B6 yeah so we
go
what do we go now F4 could even be no F4
is still not a problem we go
A4 we go A4 stopping B5 but also now
with some ideas of Bishop captures
because then if B6
A5 so yeah he he has to stop that and uh
yeah now we just grab more space here I
guess we grab more space and we're happy
with that maybe the there is probably
something better I just don't want to
invest too much time I will wait for him
to to make a
move if he does nothing like he could
offer a knight trade which is
fine yeah Knight trade is definitely
okay
here
uh
huh yeah I guess we double up on the E
file and that's it we don't have much
from from the position but hopefully
neither does
he or she I don't know I have no idea
who I'm
playing so Rook to E1 is the is the move
that I'm hoping to get in and the long
term what would my plan be well
obviously try to take advantage of the
of the pawns here if I can they either a
strength or a weakness we'll see okay so
he does go for the knight move uh as he
should and I should probably do I trade
here his Knight does have
some interesting squares if I if I don't
trade yeah we're going to trade
here we're going to
trade
yeah rookie one is the rookie one is the
move that sort of
uh yeah is Rook D5 anything if I play
Rook E1 then
B4 very
interesting let's go Rook e
one Rook d
five I actually have no idea what I had
in mind uh against Rook
D5 I was looking at some Bishop to A7
action but yeah I thought I thought uh I
I will calculate that if he plays Rook
to D5 no he doesn't go he he goes for
this
actually
okay
so hm
yeah we'll go we'll go F4 here I like my
pawns where they are but also I feel
they can do
better if H6 we're going to play captur
captur and
G3 I guess that sort of
holds yeah we'll see we'll see what it
does
uh G4 is nothing captures is terrible
for him so I'm guessing H6 is the move
here unless he's now no H6 is the move
he plays H6 we have to trade and play G3
to stop
uh to stop anything from advancing to F4
and then we then we slowly shift our
Rooks to the file uh hopefully he
doesn't react to
that yeah
he doesn't like that but also I think
that it's not bad for him or anything he
might even trade Bishops yeah no he's
not going to yeah we go
here um and get King get King G2 in for
the moment perhaps not that relevant but
we do want our King on a light Square he
does have a dark Square Bishop so it's
going to come in handy at some
point yeah but now he actually might
shift his attention to the E file uh as
he's not uh coming here anytime soon he
might play Rook D3 it's very active yeah
okay now he goes after
this uh I thought as
much I thought as
much
um yeah it's not the best not the best
so I give up the a pawn for shifting my
Rooks here and then he cannot defend the
F Pawn himself is that the way to
go
yeah oh this is this is not the the most
active way to play but I actually don't
see anything better
yeah okay now if he shifts his attention
to the E file I do have to bring the
king over
here uh now now he can even deliver a
check here okay so he does
that yeah I put my king on F2 instead of
G2 to be closer to the center if he goes
here okay then we're going to go back
but uh yeah he does he goes after the
pawn as he
should
yeah okay we have to go up the C3
Pawn we have to give it
up but he's going to play Rook D3 he's
not even going to take
it not even going to take it he's Rook
D3 then we play C4 and then he goes
after the
pawn uh this
way yeah very very nice very nice indeed
we're going to have to sacrifice one
Pawn for activity
here something like Bishop to C5
followed by Rook to E6 maybe getting
this bishop out of the way and then
creating a pass Pawn on the H file okay
he's up a minute which is a lot
so and Rook to D3 does seem like but he
doesn't have to rush with Rook to D3 as
I I really don't have any moves that are
supremely active no he's going to trade
he's going to trade very
nice he's going to
trade I like
it yeah okay so he does get quite a lot
for
this uh okay now it's either winning for
him or it's
not what if we trade Rook
yeah let him capture the pawn if he
captures the pawn then we're going to
consider a rook
trade I just want to get my Pawn uh up
the board as much as possible before
before trading yeah if he captures with
the bishop that's pretty bad I think
that's winning for
me uh yeah he goes here with the King
right away of course he does doesn't
allow this let's go let's go
H5 yeah let's go
H6 and he's going to go Bishop
G7 but no Bishop G7 loses on the
spot he might even take it he does have
some pawns here and I'm down to minute
20 no he goes for this I don't know why
or how he's planning on dealing with
this but okay
yeah I think he just blundered that it
comes with
check yeah Rook D2
now no stopping the queening
sorry yeah that was uh really strange
game really strange
indeed uh if C5 I'm not going to rush it
with the queen I might even play Bishop
here I just uh trade down as much as
possible or we should just take the
queen yeah
it's
very not the best not the best I was I
was hoping to get a uh a better game out
of this but uh obviously I have no idea
how to play against the pet at this
level uh so I will I will use this game
uh to grow and to improve okay so he
does something that
uh uh of course is very nice he he's
trying to trick me he wants to unpin and
now get his Bishop in so what's the
cleanest wait to win this let's go after
the
bishop
okay yeah that's great let's go here
after the pawn we will have to play a
few more
moves we check the
king oh no he's just going to give me
the pawn no he's going to allow the
check okay let's go
here sort of to go after the bishop
he goes here okay let's capture
here okay uh we deliver a check get out
get out of our way Mr
King we go here take everything take
everything from him he doesn't want to
allow it okay now we take the
bishop we take it even like this
okay good game Mr Angel like
uh now onto the fun part let's see what
we what we did terrible and if if there
was even a a moment where we play this
uh
okay okay so let's see so this is all
pretty standard like we said you can
challenge the pet many ways D4 I think
is the main way to do it uh the the
bishop D3 is The Bishop's attack against
the pet and I played C3 okay I think
that you can Castle here you can play C4
you can play C3 but um yeah C3 seem
seemed to be more solid because I don't
know how to play it uh Knight bd2 okay
F5 I Castle ah G4 immediately so F5
should be met with G4
immediately
okay uh and why is
that why can't you just
capture oh because Knight captures okay
so yeah and this is obviously fine for
white so see that's something that you
should know if you play such a line and
you will not be weirded out by F5 like I
was so so I played very passively
against F5 I castled uh which is still
fine obviously 0 0 uh Rook to E1 Bishop
to E7 Soul 0 0 I played Knight E3 okay
so Knight to G3 again
better why do I miss everything why is
Knight G3 better why should I have given
up this Pawn because the Bish captures
on F5 okay so we're missing stuff but
still even with Bishop captures on F5 I
felt like
this is too much yeah okay I play that
G5 and he says go for the immediate
Knight captures and G5 so
why enlighten me oh because the bishop
on H5 is saying yeah so there were quite
a few tactics that we could have done
better but uh yeah my move is yeah the
engine ranks it pretty much the same 0
point uh five in White's in Black's
favor Bishop captures an E2 Rook
captures Knight cap captures Pawn
captures Queen captures and I play Queen
captures on D5 yeah this is just z0 yeah
but now he played Bishop to D6 and he's
uh sort of much
worse oh here I had the immediate Knight
captures on F5 yeah I seem to be too
hungry or
something or or or just bad at chess
what you what are you going to do A4
okay so it's still I mean I I wasn't
worse at any point in the game and when
I say worse I mean like minus one and a
half at least minus two uh because I
always like to point out what Anish giri
said the position is either winning or
it's not doesn't matter if it's minus
one -2 minus three some positions you
can hold with minus two and a half some
you cannot hold you know with with plus
one and a half you just have to allow
the engine to Crunch the numbers and
then the engine will of course say it's
plus 100 uh but yeah it's it's either
winning or it's not so here okay still
everything
fine uh yeah we
uh he's still better here but no yeah
now King D7 he should have captured the
pawn he rushed with the King and then he
just uh completely lost the thread of
the game here yeah uh which is weird as
he was much better on time but yeah we
were able to now take complete control
over the game yeah now okay now we're
plus plus a million
so uh it was okay uh until this point
but yeah it was uh not the best opening
play middle game also yeah we held we
held it to a draw uh yeah missing that
F5 move really put me in a difficult
spot and that's something that you
should definitely know it's a it's sort
of a not a move that you will see people
play because it's not a good move by
black but if you don't know it in Rapid
or Blitz or or in bullet you know you
will you will get in trouble for
avoiding it yeah just capture and then
capture on F5 if the engine says you
know the engine is our
Overlord uh we we have to listen to it
uh so yeah I wasn't able to play this
like like Bruce Lee wanted to be like
water but in the end we did we did get a
win out of it we we were we endured the
end game we we put up a fight we were
persistent and somehow somehow we won uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it see see you in the next one
again uh do use hashtag suggestion if
you want me to try out different
openings maybe some openings that you
play uh and uh yeah we we'll see we'll
see how it goes I I will give it a shot
uh I even could play the French I mean I
don't mind uh you know I'll probably
lose terribly but I don't mind so yeah
once again hope you enjoyed it and yeah
see you soon with the next
one